Cuando pensamos en Nepal,
solemos pensar en las montañas nevadas del Himalaya,
en las tranquilas aguas cristalinas de sus lagos de montaña,
o en la enorme extensión de sus pastizales.
Lo que algunos no advierten
es que en las estribaciones del Himalaya,
donde el clima es mucho más cálido
y el paisaje mucho más verde,
vive una gran diversidad de fauna,
incluyendo el rinoceronte de un cuerno,
el elefante asiático
y el tigre de Bengala.
Pero, por desgracia, estos animales
están bajo la constante amenaza de los cazadores furtivos
que los persiguen y los matan por sus partes.
Para detener la matanza de estos animales,
se envían batallones de soldados y guardas
a proteger los parques nacionales de Nepal,
pero no es tarea fácil,
porque estos soldados tienen que patrullar
miles de hectáreas de bosques a pie
o en lomos de elefante.
También es riesgoso para estos soldados cuando
enfrentan tiroteos con los cazadores furtivos,
y por eso en Nepal se buscan
nuevas formas de proteger los bosques
y la fauna.
Recientemente Nepal adquirió una nueva herramienta
para enfrentar el crimen contra la fauna,
y son los drones,
o, más específicamente, los drones de conservación.
Desde hace cerca de un año, junto con mis colegas
hemos construido drones para Nepal
y capacitado al personal de protección del parque
en el uso de estos drones.
Un dron no solo da una vista del paisaje a vuelo de pájaro,
sino que también permite una captura en detalle,
de imágenes de alta resolución de los objetos en el suelo.
Esto, por ejemplo, es un par de rinocerontes
que toman un baño refrescante en un día caluroso de verano
en las tierras bajas de Nepal.
Creemos que los drones tienen un potencial enorme,
no solo para combatir el crimen contra la fauna,
sino también para monitorear la salud
de las poblaciones de fauna silvestre.
¿Qué es un dron?
Bueno, el tipo de dron del que estoy hablando
es simplemente un modelo de avión
equipado con un sistema de piloto automático,
con una pequeña computadora,
un GPS, una brújula, un altímetro barométrico
y algunos otros sensores.
Un avión no tripulado como este
puede llevar carga útil,
como una videocámara
o una cámara fotográfica.
También requiere un software que le permita al usuario
programar la misión,
para decirle al dron a dónde ir.
Muchas personas a menudo se sorprenden
cuando se enteran de que estos son los únicos
cuatro componentes que constituyen uno de estos drones,
pero se sorprenden aún más
cuando les digo lo económicos que son estos componentes.
De hecho, un dron de conservación
no cuesta mucho más que una buena computadora portátil
o un par de binoculares decente.
Ahora que construyeron su propio dron de conservación,
quizá quieran volarlo,
pero ¿cómo volar un dron?
Bueno, en realidad, uno no lo hace,
porque el dron vuela por sí mismo.
Uno solo programa una misión
para indicarle al dron a dónde volar.
Para eso sencillamente pulsa
sobre algunos puntos en la interfaz de Google Maps
mediante un software de código abierto.
Esas misiones pueden ser muy simples
y tener pocos puntos,
o un poco más largas y más complicadas,
como sobrevolar un sistema fluvial.
A veces volamos el dron en un patrón de tipo cortadora de césped,
tomamos fotos de esa zona,
y esas imágenes pueden ser procesadas
para producir un mapa del bosque.
Otros investigadores podrían querer volar el dron
por los límites de un bosque
para vigilar cazadores furtivos o transeuntes
que tratan de entrar al bosque ilegalmente.
Pero cualquiera que sea la misión,
una vez programada,
sencillamente se carga al sistema de piloto automático,
se lleva el dron al terreno,
y se pone en marcha simplemente arrojándolo al aire.
A menudo la misión consistirá
en tomar fotos o videos por el camino.
Generalmente en ese momento
iremos en busca de una taza de café
y nos sentaremos relajados durante unos minutos,
aunque algunos entremos en pánico en los siguientes minutos
por temor a que el dron no regrese.
Por lo general lo hace, y cuando lo hace,
incluso aterriza de forma automática.
¿Qué podemos hacer con un dron de conservación?
Cuando construimos el primer prototipo de dron,
nuestro principal objetivo era sobrevolar
una selva remota en el norte de Sumatra, Indonesia,
en busca de una especie de gran simio
conocido como orangután.
Queríamos hacerlo porque
necesitábamos saber cuántos ejemplares
de esta especie quedaban en el bosque.
El método tradicional de inspección
de orangutanes consiste en caminar por el bosque a pie
llevando equipos pesados
y con un par de binoculares mirar hacia las copas de los árboles
en busca de orangutanes o de sus nidos.
Como podrán ver,
es un proceso que lleva mucho tiempo, mucho trabajo
y es muy costoso.
Esperábamos que los drones
pudieran reducir significativamente el costo de la búsqueda
de poblaciones de orangutanes en Indonesia
y otros lugares del sudeste asiático.
Por eso fue emocionante capturar
imágenes del primer par de nidos de orangután.
Y aquí está; esta es la primera imagen
de nidos de orangután tomadas con un dron.
Como tomamos fotos de decenas de nidos
de diversas partes del sudeste asiático,
estamos trabajando con científicos informáticos,
desarrollando algoritmos que puedan contar de forma automática
la cantidad de nidos a partir de las miles
de fotos tomadas hasta ahora.
Estos drones no solo pueden detectar nidos.
Este orangután en su hábitat
se alimenta feliz en la copa de una palmera,
aparentemente ajeno a nuestro dron que sobrevoló la zona,
no una, sino varias veces.
También hemos tomado fotos de otros animales
incluyendo búfalos forestales en Gabón,
elefantes, e incluso nidos de tortuga.
Pero aparte de tomar fotos de los propios animales,
también captamos los hábitats donde viven estos animales,
porque queremos seguir la pista
de la salud en esos ambientes.
A veces, nos acercamos un poco
para observar lo que puede estar sucediendo
en el paisaje.
Esta es una plantación de palma de aceite en Sumatra.
Estos cultivos son un motor importante en la deforestación
en esa parte del mundo;
por eso queríamos usar esta nueva tecnología a base de drones
para hacer cuentas de la propagación de estas plantaciones
en el sudeste asiático.
También se podrían usar drones
para vigilar la tala ilegal.
Este es un bosque talado recientemente, de nuevo en Sumatra.
Incluso todavía se pueden ver los tablones
procesados que quedaron en el suelo.
Pero tal vez la parte más emocionante
de tomar fotos desde el aire
es que podríamos unir todas esas fotos
con un software especial
para confeccionar un mapa de todo el paisaje.
Este mapa nos daría información crucial
para monitorear el cambio de uso de la tierra;
para saber dónde y cómo crecen las plantaciones,
dónde se reducen los bosques,
o dónde se inician los incendios.
Se podrían procesar las imágenes aéreas
para producir en la computadora
modelos tridimensionales de los bosques.
Estos modelos no solo tienen un atractivo visual,
sino que también son geométricamente exactos,
lo que significa que los investigadores ahora pueden medir
la distancia entre los árboles,
calcular las áreas, el volumen de la vegetación, etc.,
toda información importante
para monitorear la salud de estos bosques.
Recientemente, hemos empezado a experimentar
con cámaras de imagen térmica.
Estas cámaras pueden detectar objetos emisores de calor,
y por ende, son muy útiles para detectar cazadores furtivos o fogatas en la noche.
Les he contado bastante sobre
qué son los drones de conservación,
cómo operarlos,
y qué pueden hacer por nosotros.
Ahora les contaré dónde se usan
en todo el mundo.
Construímos nuestros primeros prototipos de drones en Suiza.
Trajimos algunos a Indonesia
para hacer los primeros vuelos de prueba.
Después hemos construido drones
para nuestros colaboradores de todo el mundo,
entre ellos colegas biólogos
y socios de las principales organizaciones de conservación.
Quizá la mejor parte y la más gratificante
de trabajar con estos colaboradores
es la retroalimentación que nos dan
sobre cómo mejorar nuestros drones.
Construir drones para nosotros
es una obra en progreso constante.
Siempre tratamos de mejorarlos en materia
de rango, robustez,
y cantidad de carga que pueden transportar.
También trabajamos con colaboradores
para descubrir nuevas formas de usar estos drones.
Por ejemplo, las cámaras trampa son herramientas comunes
para los biólogos que quieren tomar imágenes de animales tímidos
que se esconden en los bosques,
Estas son cámaras sensibles al movimiento,
que se disparan cuando un animal cruza su camino.
El problema con estas cámaras
es que los investigadores tienen que volver al bosque
de vez en cuando para recuperar esas imágenes.
Eso lleva mucho tiempo,
especialmente si hay decenas
o cientos de cámaras por todo el bosque.
Se puede entonces diseñar un dron para hacer la tarea
de manera mucho más eficiente.
Este dron, con un sensor especial,
podría sobrevolar el bosque
y descargar estas imágenes de forma remota
desde cámaras con wi-fi.
Los collares con radio son otra herramienta
que los biólogos usan comúnmente.
Se le colocan a los animales.
Los collares transmiten señales de radio que le permiten
al investigador rastrear los movimientos de los animales por el paisaje.
Esta forma tradicional de rastrear animales
es bastante ridícula,
porque requiere que el investigador camine
por el terreno con una enorme y engorrosa antena de radio,
como esas viejas antenas de TV que solíamos tener en el techo.
Algunos todavía las tenemos.
Podría usarse un dron para hacer lo mismo de manera mucho más eficiente.
¿Por qué no equipar un dron con un receptor de radio de barrido,
que sobrevuele el dosel del bosque siguiendo cierto patrón
que le permita al usuario o al operador, de forma remota,
triangular la ubicación de los animales que llevan collar,
sin tener que poner un pie en el bosque.
Una tercera manera, y quizá la más interesante,
de usar estos drones
es sobrevolar selvas muy remotas
nunca antes exploradas
en algún lugar oculto de los trópicos,
y lanzar en paracaídas pequeños micrófonos
que nos permitan espiar las llamadas
de mamíferos, aves, anfibios,
el Yeti, el Sasquatch, Bigfoot, lo que sea.
Esto nos daría a los biólogos
una idea bastante clara de lo que los animales
podrían estar viviendo en los bosques.
Por último, me gustaría mostrarles
la última versión de nuestro dron de conservación.
El dron MAJA tiene una envergadura de unos dos metros.
Pesa solo unos dos kilos,
pero puede transportar la mitad de su peso.
Es un sistema totalmente autónomo.
Durante su misión, incluso puede transmitir
video en vivo de respuesta a una laptop en tierra,
lo que le permite al usuario
ver lo que está viendo el dron, en tiempo real.
Lleva una serie de sensores,
de modo que la calidad de sus fotos
puede llegar a uno o dos centímetros por pixel.
El dron puede permanecer en el aire durante 40 a 60 minutos,
lo que le da un rango de hasta 50 kilómetros
que es suficiente para la mayoría de las aplicaciones de conservación.
Los drones de conservación empezaron como una idea alocada de dos biólogos
a los que les apasiona esta tecnología.
Creemos, firmemente,
que los drones pueden ser y serán un elemento de cambio
para la investigación y las aplicaciones de conservación.
Hemos tenido nuestra cuota de escépticos y críticos
que pensaban que estábamos manipulando aviones de juguete.
Y en cierto modo, tienen razón.
Quiero decir, seamos honestos,
los drones son el mejor juguete para jóvenes.
Al mismo tiempo, también hemos llegado a conocer
muchos colegas y colaboradores maravillosos
que comparten nuestra visión
y ven el gran potencial en los drones de conservación.
Para nosotros, es obvio que los biólogos conservacionistas
y los operadores deben hacer uso pleno
de toda herramienta disponible, incluyendo los drones,
en nuestra lucha por salvar los últimos bosques
y la fauna silvestres del planeta.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)